six men tasked with maintaining Law and
Order in Democratic Republic of Congo
facing the full might of the legal
system
the senior soldiers including a colonel
and the Lutheran kennel are on trial in
a military Court in Goma they are facing
several charges among them crimes
against humanity
the action conducted by these soldiers
was a systematically planned and
targeted attack against very well
identified populations as per Army laws
and rules it's clear that the killings
perpetrated by these soldiers is a crime
against humanity
the case focuses on the Armed Forces
response to a protest against un
peacekeepers last week
dozens of people were killed or wounded
when soldiers opened fire with live
ammunition to this past the
demonstrators more than 20 patients are
still being treated at a hospital in
Goma it was a very difficult situation I
believe it's the first time we received
51 patients in more or less six hours
luckily that day we had free surgeons
and so we were able to to run three
operating theaters
but still it was really complicated
most patients have gunshot wounds in
their upper bodies
we hadn't started a protest yet we were
just meeting when the soldiers attacked
us they broke into our compound and
started shooting at us it upsets me that
some people were killed and they did
nothing wrong
I was walking home from the office I had
nothing to do with the protest I came
across two trucks one caring soldiers
and another with police officers we
heard gunshots and there was nowhere to
run I only realized later that I had
been shot in the stomach
some families don't know their relatives
whereabouts and suspect they were among
the victims
they say the Army is keeping a number of
bodies in a morgue refusing to release
them the anti-un protest was organized
by a religious sect called wazilando
which means Patriots Congolese
authorities have banned the group's
demonstrations accusing it of spreading
Anarchy the incident further complicates
the conflict in eastern Congo where
Ahmed militia fighting each other or
against the state have wreaked havoc for
decades Muhammad Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera